in the opening scene numerous tourists
are seen arriving at Thailand's airport
to visit Pattaya City among them we are
introduced to a big man named Barney
Emerald who appears to be drug and
disoriented he is half naked and is
waiting outside the police station at
the airport at this moment he remembers
the previous night where he was at a bar
a Thai woman approached Barney and
compelled him to consume excessive
amounts of alcohol once he was drunk an
unknown guy presumably an accomplice of
the woman transported him to a van and
robbed him before abandoning him
partially unclothed on the streets at
present Barney is playing with a young
girl while awaiting his turn to speak
with a police officer when his turn
finally comes he explains everything
that happened last night and seeks
assistance in apprehending the woman in
response the police officer pong
mentions that they have already started
an investigation into the matter but it
may take several days this causes
concern for Barney as he lacks money and
has nowhere to go moreover his passports
and other documents were all stolen by
the thieves hearing all this pong
provides him with a letter and 50 bot in
cash for bus fare advising him to
contact the tourist information center
Barney expresses his gratitude for the
generous act and to departs after waving
goodbye to his young friend following
this he takes a scooter ride and heads
towards the tourist center only to learn
that it's closed for renovation now with
no money and nowhere to stay Barney
wanders through the streets for a while
before finding a spot to rest on the
pathway shortly after a girl named
catton suddenly comes running towards
him she appears to be chased by some bad
guys however Barney pays little
attention to this as he is already
dealing with his own troubles the bad
guys soon approach him and inquire if he
has seen the girl but Barney who is
unable to understand their language
simply tells him I don't know this
annoys the guys and they decide to leave
without causing any trouble meanwhile as
Barney leans against a food menu board
behind him he is startled by the girl's
scream this alerts the villains as well
and they return to capture the girl
Bernie also gets up to avoid the
commotion but seeing his tall and
imposing physique the gangsters get
scared they believe that Barney's about
to defend the girl so they arm
themselves to confront him but right
then a tuck tuck passes by with a loud
noise which surprisingly frightens
Barney as he cowers in fear the
gangsters laugh at him realizing that he
is weak they then launch an attack on
Captain but she swiftly hides beneath
Barney who takes the blows intended for
her just when it seems that the two are
going to get battered catton's sister
dokya arrives at the scene dokyo appears
to be a professional Muay Thai Fighter
and using her deadly moves she easily
defeats the bad guys ultimately the
girls utilize Barney to trap the
gangsters before making their escape
completely bewildered by the events that
unfolded Barney repeatedly apologizes to
the guys claiming that he never intended
to harm them later on dokyo inquires
with catton about why the men were
pursuing her the latter places the blame
on Barney but it is eventually revealed
that she had pickpocketed one of the
gangsters afterward while on their their
way back home the two sisters
unexpectedly encounter Barney who
returns some of the accessories cat and
had left behind witnessing his
generosity the girls decide to bring
Barney along to their Monastery and
offer him a place to spend the night
upon arrival they introduce Barney to a
senior monk who grants him permission to
stay there until he finds his passport
the monk also instructs catton to find
some suitable clothing for the
half-naked giant Barney then shares
sleeping quarters with other children in
the monastery but he ends up disturbing
them with his loud snores on the other
hand we see two foreigners named Adam
and Smith meeting of local Thai
businessman named narong the foreigners
reveal a special laptop device to him
featuring a concealed compartment that
can only be unlocked using a
diamond-like crystal key elsewhere a
valuable Camellia Diamond set is being
transported to a highly secure safe it
is then revealed that the set was
brought to Thailand for the world
jewelry fair the following morning the
children wake Barney up and he proceeds
to accompany the monks around town
assisting them with their rituals
throughout the day Barney engages in
various activities with the children
including communal meals and helping
with Monastery chores in the afternoon
captain and dokyo bring him to their
mother's small restaurant at the beach
the woman is taken aback by Barney's
giant physique but nonetheless she
welcomes him warmly they offer him a
taste of famous local Cuisine a dish
called somtum however upon taking his
first bite the intense spiciness of the
dish causes Barney to turn red and
uncontrollable he morphs into a
hulk-like beast and desperately searches
for water unfortunately in the process
he accidentally wreaks havoc in the
restaurant and even strikes their mother
geez I'm starting a petition to get
Barney on hot ones after Barney finally
calms down he expresses remorse for his
actions explaining that he had lost
control over his body he promises to do
whatever he can to earn money and help
rebuild the damaged restaurant this
strikes Captain's mind and she comes up
with an idea to train him for a fight
club she shares this concept with dokyo
who agrees to take on the task of
training him thus Barney's rigorous
training commences from that day forth
dokyo teaches Muay Thai techniques to
him and even arranges for him to spar
with a young boy but despite Bernie's
big body he is easily beaten up by the
boy amidst these training sessions
Barney also opens up about his
unfortunate past he reveals that he had
won a trip to Pattaya through a lucky
draw which brought him to Thailand only
to be robbed on his very first day in
the meantime a television news broadcast
reports on the theft of the Camellia
Diamond set it is later revealed that
narong Adam and Smith are the ones
behind the heist they conceal the stolen
diamonds within their specialized laptop
and discuss the next phase of their plan
which involves delivering the package to
Brunei in order to receive payment
however since they have a few more days
remaining in Thailand they decide to
enjoy every moment of their time there
in the following scene captain and
Barney are walking together when the
latter notices the bar girl who had
previously robbed him alarmed he chases
after her with Captain following closely
behind coincidentally officer pong
observes the pursuit and begins is
following them as well after a while
Barney arrives at the girls Hideout and
discovers a collection of stolen
passports not wanting any trouble he
simply requests for his own passport but
the robbers start attacking him
fortunately pong arrives in the nick of
time and beats up the criminals one by
one as he takes them into custody
Captain manages to find Barney's
passport but she secretly hides it in
her bag later that evening the sisters
are concerned about how they can earn
money to support their mother as their
conversation unfolds they devise a plan
and Catherine approaches their mother
asking for permission for dokyo to
participate in a Muay Thai dancing
contest however their true intention is
for dokyo to engage in a boxing match
and earn money believing it to be a
harmless dancing contest their mother
grants them consent to proceed the next
day the Two Sisters accompanied by
Barney visit the fight club and approach
the organizer named Yong requesting a
match for dokyo coincidentally narong
and his gang who are responsible for the
stolen Diamond set are also present
there soon doki's fight is announced but
to her dismay she is pitted against a
male opponent making their match totally
unfair nonetheless Doki refuses to back
down as she requires the money for her
mother's sake as per the rules if dokyo
emerges victorious she will win up to 10
times the amount of the BET placed on
the match soon the fight begins and in
the initial moments docus showcases her
skills deftly evading her opponent's
attacks however during the second round
the opponent discreetly hides a blade
within his boxing gloves and mercilessly
Cuts dokie's face the injury nearly
causes her to lose Consciousness yet she
manages to summon the strength to rise
once more despite the unfair tactics
employed by her opponent the courageous
girl continues to fight valiantly
eventually knocking him to the ground
witnessing this Yan quickly signals the
referee to ring the bell concluding the
match in a draw after the fight the trio
approaches young to collect doki's prize
money but to their dismay they are only
handed a mere thousand Bots upon
requesting a larger sum Yang summons his
men
them up elsewhere at the hotel room the
Diamond Thieves find themselves in a
state of panic as they realize that
they've lost the Crystal Key narong
suggests forcefully opening the laptop
but Smith cautions against it fearing
that such an act could potentially
damage its contents in an attempt to
locate the missing key they review the
CCTV footage specifically focusing on
the fight club to their astonishment
they spot Caton stealing the key when
they were distracted now with time
running out the robbers hire a bald guy
and offer him 100 Grand to apprehend
captain in the next scene we see Barney
who now works in the fish market he
utilizes his earnings to purchase
construction materials in order to
rebuild the restaurant that he had
accidentally destroyed earlier a few
days later they construct a new and
improved restaurant which appears to be
more spacious the family wastes no time
and starts their business from the very
evening Barney is assigned the task of
grinding food but due to his strength he
breaks a few mortars as a result catton
comes up with the idea of acquiring a
large mortar that will perfectly suit
the big guy and as the days pass by the
restaurant begins to gain in popularity
attracting both locals and visitors who
wish to try the famous Thai Dish
sometime one evening Barney the two
sisters and their mother come together
to celebrate doki's birthday as a gift
cotton presents her with a necklace
crafted from the same crystal key seeing
this Doki becomes suspicious and
questions whether the necklace was
acquired through theft however cotton
lies that it is a fake item the
following day Barney and the two sisters
are strolling along the streets when a
van abruptly blocks their path a group
of men get out from the vehicle and
abduct all three of them after this
they're taken to the diamond robbers who
begin to interrogate them about the
whereabouts of the Crystal Key soon
enough Adam discovers the key hanging
from doki's neck and snatches it away
but in a shocking turn of events narong
turns against his gang members pointing
a gun at them he wants to take the
reward all for himself sensing the
Betrayal Adam forcefully makes Doki
scream in agony before dropping the
Crystal Key into her mouth as the gang
members fight amongst themselves dokyo
seizes the opportunity to escape from
the scene in response narang orders some
of his accomplices to pursue her while
instructing the others to eliminate
Barney and Captain the two are then
pinned against a wall ready to be
punished but right then Captain notices
a plate of some Tom nearby acting
swiftly she feeds the spicy dish to
Barney causing him to transform into a
furious red giant with his strength
Barney defeats the bad guys easily
before rushing to rescue dokyo on the
way he runs into three formidable
wrestlers who are there to stop him they
start beating him up and seeing this
cotton decides to prepare another batch
of extremely spicy sometime using some
nearby ingredients as soon as she gets
the chance she feeds it all to Barney
once again triggering his uncontrollable
transformation into a destructive Giant
and just like before he overpowers and
defeats those wrestlers meanwhile Toki
tries to evade the pursuing gangsters
engaging in fights along the way however
her efforts prove futile as she is
ultimately captured by the bald man who
holds her at gunpoint Barney sees this
from a distance so he rushes to a rescue
tragically he is shot by no rang causing
him to collapse on the ground as he
rides in pain dokyo approaches him with
tears in her eyes and Returns His
passport she apologizes for concealing
it from him saying that she feared he
would leave her Bernie is moved by the
words and when he opens the passport he
finds a sketch depicting him with his
sisters meanwhile no rang once again
reconciles with Adam and Smith who shoot
the bald guy before dragging dokyo to
their private jet then the robbers are
about to dissect her to take the crystal
while Bernie summons his remaining
strength and lunges towards the plane
inside the aircraft no rang's demeanor
suddenly changes and he again turns
against his foreign accomplices stabbing
Adam but as a consequence Adam also
manages to shoot him resulting in the
demise of both of them Barney then
confronts Smith in a fierce battle while
Doki makes her escape from the plane as
Bernie defeats his final enemy he
succumbs to his injuries and collapses
onto the floor witnessing this the Two
Sisters rushed to his side and start
crying in a desperate attempt to revive
the Man Captain asks Barney to open his
mouth so that she can feed him some
sometime miraculously upon hearing her
words the giant man regains
Consciousness and runs away saying he
will never consume the dish again the
movie ends as we learn that Barney has
returned to his native country he has
also brought Captain along with him for
a short holiday trip
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching